all right so let's talk a little about
some webassembly stuff
um basically the first thing that we're
going to talk about today is
the webassembly format itself um
so uh basically like wasm is a binary
format we're going to talk about what
that means we're going to talk about
what's in it
i think a lot of web developers haven't
dealt with binary formats before so
we're going to like
demystify it a little bit and then we're
going to talk about how
web assembly has some challenges when it
comes to debugging
it's definitely not impossible it's just
a little different and there's a bunch
of stuff going on there
and as part of that we're going to be
talking about some things called elf
dwarf and source maps um i made a little
tolkien joke there
uh there's some some good puns going on
in this space
around these kind of tools so that's
kind of what we're going to get into is
like the details of the wasm format
stuff about debugging that kind of thing
so uh what is the
wasm format in the first place so
we didn't really like i sort of assumed
there's like this dot wasn't format but
let's talk about like what that means
now it fits into webassembly
so webassembly is a specification that
is standard by
the w3c like many other web standards
although the watt wg is also doing some
standardization nowadays
uh the w3c is the like you know sort of
og
standards body and so um as
that means that in some sense
webassembly is like a specification
and then there's software that
implements that specification so
that means there's a lot of like details
and stuff that's kind of like outside of
the spec
that still is practical when it comes to
actually using a thing right like
standard says like this is what exists
but you
don't that doesn't necessarily mean that
it covers everything that matters to
like day-to-day development when you're
actually using the technology
um and so this talk is kind of a little
bit the first part is about what's in
the standard
the second part is about all this stuff
that's being done outside of the
standard to make it sort of usable for
many people
um and uh i'm going to be
uh like talking a lot about the spec the
specification is really good
if you haven't read a lot of
specifications before i think the
webassembly standard is a great way to
get started learning specifications
maybe i've read too many older or bad
specifications before
but i really really like the webassembly
spec and i think it's fantastic
for getting started um if you haven't
read specs before you may find it like a
little bit confusing like obviously if
you give it a try and you struggle don't
worry about it
but it's just it's more manageable than
other specifications from what i found
especially given the like amount of
detail that it goes into which is
helpful when you're trying to learn
about the details but can also be a
little overwhelming for times
and so uh you can read all of it on the
web i'm going to be posting some
screenshots of it in this presentation
but if you go to webassembly.github.io
spec you can actually read the whole
thing and when i have screenshots
they're from various parts
of that specification so
there's sort of these actually the
webassembly spec defines these sort of
two big
situations um not really the right word
but whatever
um it defines web assembly itself but
also this thing called a host
environment
and this is one of the things i really
love about webassembly is that it's very
forward thinking
so um so the web assembly spec defines
web assembly itself
and that has a number of these sort of
like tops
top level sections and they sort of
describe what makes up webassembly so
there's kind of
the structure of what webassembly is and
then
validation which is a really interesting
thing i'll get to in a second
how webassembly is executed and then
finally two different formats
one is a binary format and one is a
textual format the binary format uses
the dot wasm extension
and the text uses the watt extension
for web assembly text but is also kind
of just a general joke
um i think that the the folks that made
wasm knew that would be kind of funny
and so they uh they ended up picking
that
um so most of the time you would like
so it's important to understand this
distinction because there's kind of like
the structure of a webassembly program
is sort of like abstract and then the
binary and text formats are the like
representation of how that format is
defined in the computer
but you could make alternate formats if
you wanted to and in fact there was a
competing textual format for a little
while
um but it sort of coalesced around this
dot watt format um so like they did a
really nice job of splitting out the
sort of like abstract description from
the actual bits of
how you represent that abstract
description which is really cool
um it also means like this validation
section is really cool because
webassembly has several ways that you
can sort of like validate that it's
well-formed
um in the first place so as sort of an
example
uh you can verify that the types that
are in
because webassembly is typed i don't
really talk about that exactly
but you can validate that all the types
match up without actually
executing any of the webassembly itself
this is really important for
security properties on the web for
example it's really important that
you're able to check that certain
properties exist
ahead of time and that's like a really
cool aspect and so they describe
how you would go about validating a
bunch of these properties without
actually needing to run the code itself
and then the execution describes a
little bit about the how the
web assembly programs are actually
executed and you can do this in a number
of different ways and we'll get into
that in a little bit
um so that's like webassembly proper um
and
uh then there's also this host
environment so
it's it's like webassembly is always
defined as running in the context of
some other thing
which sounds sort of weird until you
think about regular programs right like
regular programs
very rarely run on their own they're
almost always run in the context of say
an operating system some programs are
operating systems
they run in the context of hardware so
we're kind of like almost always
inside of some other thing when we're
talking about software and webassembly
makes that explicit
and separate which is really cool
because it means that things are more
flexible
and so there's kind of this running joke
that like web assembly
is neither web nor assembly um and so
like webassembly is actually broader
than the web itself
because the people who wrote the spec
were able to separate out the web parts
from the non-web parts um
so like the spec talks about having an
embedder
that embeds the web assembly like
runtime
inside of itself and how those
boundaries operate and so there's kind
of two
embedders that are in the specification
itself as well
this is the javascript and web embedders
but anyone can sort of like define their
own
um other sort of embedding framework and
we're going to talk about at least one
more of those later in this presentation
but um kind of the way you might think
about like what's the difference between
javascript and web
well it's sort of the same way that like
you have node in the browser
um you know javascript is also broader
than the web and can run
outside of a web browser context so they
they very cleanly separated out the
stuff that's needed for
a javascript embedding in a pure
javascript setting
and then one that would be in the
context of the web platform and how that
would happen
so a lot of people tend to think about
webassembly as being this thing that's
built into the web platform
but it's it's significantly broader and
kind of always has been um
you know javascript was built inside the
web platform and kind of pulled out
the foresight was there to actually make
it separate in the first place
and this distinction is going to become
very important when we talk about
debugging
because how debugging works is different
based on what host environment you have
um so that's part of this challenge
which is why i bring this up
this is one of my favorite aspects of
webassembly but it's not just because i
love it it's because it's actually like
relevant to the stuff we're going to be
talking about
uh here pretty soon so i sort of gave a
small overview of these already but i'm
going to talk about each of these four
sections just briefly
um so the structure like webassembly is
its own programming language in a sense
um but it has different actual concrete
representations like i said the binary
and text format
and so they have a common structure so
that's what this like part of the
specification
um talks about is this abstract
structure
um so i mentioned before the validation
is important because you can check that
certain things make sense
um and so like there's like this type
system that's involved and it specifies
all of the things that happen
inside and so one of the things i think
is really cool though and
the cool thing about the web assembly
spec is that
it says here all rules are given in two
equivalent forms
in prose describing the meaning in an
intuitive form and a formal notation
describing it in mathematical form
so a lot of specifications choose one or
the other webassembly decided to choose
both
if you're a mathy kind of person you
want to do the like formal version
that's like great
it's much more concise but if you're not
really a mathy person like i'm not
really that mathy of a person to be
honest with you i tend to read the prose
version of this which sort of describes
it in words
and they consider both of them canonical
so if there's a bug
if there's something that diverges
between these two explanations they
consider that a bug
this is i think really helpful for
making the spec accessible to folks
it's just like really nice it's cool to
see them put in the work to do both
versions
so executing so what happens is
webassembly has this thing called
modules so
the unit in webassembly is a module and
so webassembly code gets executed when
you instantiate a module
and then you call a function and so ha
that is like kind of what kicks off the
process of running things
in languages that have like a main
function you could imagine that being
something like main
uh in languages that don't you can
imagine that as being when you load up a
file into your interpreter or whatever
and so this describes like how the thing
gets executed and importantly this is
also described in relatively abstract
terms
um and so uh this allows you to have
multiple different implementations
so for example browsers tend to
implement webassembly in terms of the
javascript
runtime they reuse parts of their
javascript virtual machine to implement
webassembly
but folks have actually built their own
webassembly
runtimes that exist totally separate
from everything else and that's enabled
by building out this like execution
specification
um and so that's like another really
cool area of flexibility
um if you happen to know what this means
uh this is a positive thing but
uh webassembly is a stack machine um
so if you don't know what that means
don't worry about it it's not that
really that important
we're not going to talk about that
aspect of wasm but there are other talks
you can get into that sort of talk about
what that means
basically in virtual machines there's
two major kind of like architectures one
is a stack architecture and one's a
register architecture
and uh wasm is a stack machine not a
registered machine
i don't have enough time to talk about
the details there but that's just like
kind of an interesting side effect
um same thing here prose and formal
definition which is really cool
um finally the binary and text format
so the binary format uh basically is
just like put
the syntax into binary and then the uh
watt format uh is the text format and it
turns things into s expressions
so if you loved lisp then lisp lives on
inside of webassembly
there's sort of an interesting history
here where javascript was like
some people wanted it to be a lisp in
the first place and a lot of the folks
who wrote early javascript are very big
list people
this is kind of like a joke the lisp's
revenge is that uh webassembly is like
has this
s expression style syntax but um we're
going to look at both of these formats
um in the rest of the presentation but
an interesting property of it when it
comes to debugging
is that these formats are equivalent so
you can take the text format and turn it
into binary
and you can take the binary format and
turn it into text and so
the advantage of the binary format is
that it is smaller and more compact
and if you think about you know when
you're downloading an asset over the
internet you want it to be as small and
compact as possible
so that is tends to be how things are
used in that sense
but if you want to read it you know many
people don't read binary
um although there are some embedded
folks who uh you know
work with it every day and so develop a
certain amount of ability to kind of
like
see the code as you will um but uh most
people would want to look at stuff in
the text format and so
being able to make this happen is
something that like is important um it
was like a really key part of making
sure that
you know the web like you can read the
javascript code that is running in your
browser at least in theory
um and so it was important there'd be a
text format too
um to keep that kind of property
okay so host environments um i talked a
little bit about the browser earlier and
you can run webassembly in your browser
um this is following all the w3 c3
specifications around the browser
host environment and there's more work
to be done here that's actually very
interesting
the one that everyone loves to talk
about is dom access um
and so like right now web assembly can't
directly access the dom
it can call into javascript code though
and javascript can touch the dom so you
kind of get this
chain process where if you want
webassembly to do dom manipulation it
calls in the javascript and javascript
does the work
there's a proposal that would let
webassembly sort of not just
interact with the dom directly but
interact with sort of any kind of like
external resource that the host might
want to expose
and it's called the host bindings
proposal and so that will be a thing
that
happens that allows this to work but
there's a bunch of other stuff you can
imagine that would be useful
inside of webassembly that does not
exist today so there's more work
happening in that
in that browser environment there's also
what's i'm calling sort of like the
system environment
so i mentioned before that like uh you
know you can run wasm outside of a
browser
and you need to define you know ways of
making that happen
um mozilla and other folks have come up
with a specification called wazi which
stands for webassembly
systems interface and it kind of defines
the ability for webassembly to talk to
file systems
the network on its own without dealing
with the browser
graphics audio input encryption like all
this other kind of stuff that you might
expect from
a application that's running natively as
opposed to in the browser
um and so this has been kind of like a
um there's several other
people that are involved in this spec
and it's kind of gaining steam as sort
of the de facto
way to run webassembly programs outside
of the browser
and so this is kind of really really
cool and so we get the ability to like
run webassembly programs
outside of the browser as well and
there's tons of reasons why that might
be
valuable valuable to folks i don't have
time to get into them
entirely in this talk so i'm just going
to kind of say that's useful and sort of
leave it at that
as part of this there all of these
things i just covered could be its own
talk on its own
if i moved a little quickly and you got
a little lost don't worry because
there's just so
so so many things going on here and
there's a rich amount of information to
learn
and so i could give a 45 minute talk
about almost every single one of these
probably multiple talks about many parts
of all the stuff that i just
described we're going to focus on one
particular aspect though
which is the binary format itself and
how that impacts debugging
because as i mentioned like if you're
doing webassembly stuff in a browser
you're probably downloading the binary
format and executing it because you want
that small
size that a binary format affords you
and you're probably going to want to be
able to like debug your application
so you sort of need to confront this and
i think this is an area where
it's a lot of interesting and active
development and so
this also i think really matters because
as i sort of mentioned
briefly before a lot of people as i made
up this kind of quote on the right hand
side here
a lot of people think that like they're
fearful about webassembly because they
know that javascript
you're able to read the code that comes
into your browser and that's like an
important property of them
um and so that's also sort of basically
a version of debugging like i want to
know what my browser is executing i'll
be able to read it that's like
fundamentally a debugging process and so
i think that
talking about debugging is really
important for getting the folks that are
a little worried about this on board
with webassembly is kind of like a
general thing
um okay so uh
dot wasm files the binary format how do
you get a dot wasm file
well fundamentally what happens is you
compile a program
into a wasm file and i say compile
because you need to sort of ahead of
time
generate the whole thing if you have a
language that's not compiled ahead of
time or i should say an implementation
because languages can be both but like
whatever you get it
um if you have sort of an interpreter
with your language you also need to
compile that interpreter as well
and so you kind of get larger binaries
with languages that need to have an
interpreter
and that's a whole other section about
webassembly that's not part of this talk
but just like you get everything your
program needs so you get a ruby program
you want to compile to webassembly you
compile not just your ruby but also the
ruby interpreter
it produces a big giant.wasm file um
and then an implementation will actually
execute that according to the execution
section and the spec
so you hand that wisem file to some sort
of uh implementation and it runs it
um and so this makes debugging really
interesting
because you know if you compile your
program into dot wasm
you don't have the source code anymore
and so this is like
step number one that's the big problem
is you sort of lose in translation
um you know if you think about a a
dynamically typed scripting language
like say
javascript or ruby or python or perl or
any of those other languages
you sort of like execute the source code
to some degree obviously there's jits
and compilers and all this other stuff
but like you step through the source
code and you see the source code kind of
like running
when you're debugging stuff but if you
compile this into webassembly
all that information is gone so like
what do we do about that
um i'm going to be using this tool
called wasm
code explorer i put the link down here
at the bottom this is a really useful
way of visualizing the binary format
and i put it here because i didn't have
room on all the slides that i'm going to
use it for later so i just wanted to
like
mention briefly that that's a really
great tool that i use all the time to
like look at webassembly binary output
so let's take a look at an actual
example of this happening so here's a
rust program
you don't really need to know rust for
this presentation this is the only rest
code in the slide
but i had to pick a language and rust
has put a lot of work into making web
assembly great
so um here on line one we use this was
on bind gen which is a thing that
generates bindings to web assembly
um and then on line four we make a
function called add one that takes a
32-bit number
and returns a 32-bit number and we add
one to it
it's pretty straightforward and that
line three that annotation says hey we
want to expose this to web assembly
so this is an example like you could
write this program in vs code or
whatever
i'm using code here and then you compile
it
via tool uh depending on you know what
language you're using
in this case i use wasm pack which is a
great tool written to
help do rust and webassembly stuff and
then you get wasm file out
um what does the dot wasn't file look
like well
here is that uh wasm explorer tool i was
showing you before
it shows you all of this binary kind of
like on the left
and then what it renders like into ascii
on the right which is kind of
interesting
but uh it also color codes all of the
individual
sections or in talk about sections in a
second and then like highlights them as
you move your mouse
over so you see that one that's like
that light blue color because i was
highlighting my mouse over when i took
the screenshot but you kind of get this
um all this binary code and so this is
the
what the rust compiler put out i
actually come about it this morning um
this is the like the outcome that comes
out of the compiler when you compile
that previous program
you get this um and so
uh this is like what we're gonna talk
about is how does this format actually
like work
um this is the equivalent.what to that
wasm so it gives you kind of this
better text representation you can see
all the parentheses because the s
expression
and they're kind of all these little
sections in between so we're going to go
back and forth and talk about
both of these things um i don't have
time to explain all of the details from
this example because i want to talk
about debugging stuff
but um this is kind of like the sort of
hello world if you will of wasm
formats so you see that first line says
module and then everything else goes
inside of it as i mentioned
a webassembly like a dot wasm file
defines some sort of wasm module
and inside the module are all these
other things called sections so we have
type memory
export export func and data and those
are
sections you can also have custom
sections and there's other types of
sections that aren't in here
but the rough structure is like the file
defines a module and then inside the
module is defines all these sections
and the sections all define different
stuff so as you can imagine that func
section defines that function that we
are
uh you know calling to add one and then
the export
you can see right above it there's a
export add one that exports that
function so it's like saying hey
i'm i want somebody outside of this
module to be able to call this function
um like i said there's a lot going on
here we're not going to get all the
details
um but uh yeah so that's kind of like
this is what's inside your computer and
then this is what you can like produce
from it to like make something that's a
little more readable
so here's an example from the spec
describing modules
so uh it says like hey there is a an
encoding of a module starts with a
preamble that contains a four byte magic
number
which is a string backslash zero asm
and then a version field the current
version is one
uh it's then followed by sections um and
like
you know you can do whatever you want
and so it says magic here zero x zero
zero
zero x six one zero x seven three zero x
0x60
and then version is one and then a bunch
of zeros and then the module section
afterwards
so if you were looking at the spec and
you're like okay how do i map this to
the binary code that's actually in the
dot wasm file
well maybe it's a little small um if you
double click
on this on the slides you get a little
bigger but you can see that that exact
same stuff the zero zero
six one seven three uh six d that dot
asm
that the first four bytes of the file
um and then that version is the next
byte so zero one zero zero zero zero
zero zero
so we can see how that spec corresponds
directly to this binary output
and um you know in lots of languages you
don't necessarily deal with binary files
a whole ton
and i wanted to whip up an example here
but i felt it was getting a little long
but the point is you can just open up
the file and read it byte by byte
um in whatever programming language you
want and if you wanted to see
like is a program a webassembly file you
would need to look at the first four
bytes and see do they match up with this
magic number um and that would let you
know that it's a webassembly file and
then you can see what version of
webassembly
it's encoded with by looking at the next
four bytes and so kind of the process of
stepping through and working with a
binary file
is literally just matching up the words
in the spec to the structure
here you can think of it just like json
right like you parse some json
you pull out the very first thing you
you know compare how it like
looks to whatever you're expecting and
you go through it exact same process
just like a little more compact
and maybe in a way that's like slightly
more awkward from higher level languages
um but uh yeah so then
um it's like uh so this is again the
like uh
the code that we had we're going to uh
now talk about this section so
the very first bit here the type section
so webassembly is typed
and so this is saying hey there's a
function that takes in a 30 i-32 is a
parameter
and returns an i-32 as a result it
happens that rust and webassembly both
share the i-32 type so even though it
was in the rust code this is the
webassembly i32 type just to be clear
but this how is this actually
represented in the webassembly file
well i'm not going to get into all the
details because this is not just like
steve reads the webassembly spec to you
but um if you look at the next bytes
that come after so we talked about the
magic number we talked about the version
field
the very next section says zero one zero
six and
in the spec i didn't actually copy paste
to this yet
um it says hey the type uh section
starts with the number zero one
so you would like expect that like okay
i need to see what
section is the first section of this
module so i read the first byte
it's zero one oh that means that this is
a type section
and the zero six um that corresponds to
the rest of it
so if you count here this one two three
four five
six there are six bytes in the sort of
like body of the type section
and so that number six is what's
encoding
how how long like how big is this
particular section
and so every section follows this kind
of rule if you look on the second line
there you'll see o302
and then two purple bits after the o2
it's the same deal
zero three is a section that corresponds
to a different part of the webassembly
spec
and then there are two bytes long so we
say okay there are going to be two bytes
for the next module
and it repeats um so you say like type
and then
the length and then you see what the
length is um
and so that's kind of like how the rough
structure of this whole file is
formatted you have like
magic byte version then a list of
sections where it goes
section type section length however many
bytes is in the length
section type section length however many
bytes in the length and you just keep
going
and going and going and so all of these
the different color codes map to
different
parts of the spec but fundamentally
that's like how the file is structured
and that's all that it is
so um you know once you get comfortable
with your language's ability to read
bytes and compare them to things
like you can whip up something that
reads the structure at least the
structure of like
how many sections are there and what are
their types is like pretty easy to get
going
um i did it in like a weekend basically
and i didn't even need to like spend all
weekend to do it it was just like in my
spare time i happened to go through
um and so it's it's like not that bad
once you get into it and then it feels
like magic because
for some reason even though like json is
also stored as binary on
on the disk working with binary formats
feels harder than working with text
formats um but like once you get into it
it's not it's not that bad
um okay so
uh this is the the example code again
um you would imagine we go to the memory
section after the type section blah blah
all those kind of things
all right so that's kind of like the the
rough
um talking about these two formats how
they relate to each other and how the
encoding
goes you can read the rest of the spec
to see the details about how all the
other sections work
i'm not going to get into those right
now because i want to talk about
challenges with debugging this thing
so obviously you wrote your rust code or
ruby
code or python code or javascript code
or whatever javascript doesn't go by the
wasm yet
sort of complicated um but uh
you probably want to be able to debug
your program so there's going to be some
issues there
first of all the main the big issue in
the first place is different people
debug differently
so some people use printf debugging as
it's called um
printf being the way that you print
strings to the screen and see
um this is actually surprisingly tricky
uh in
in webassembly uh i'll get into that in
a second uh the second one is like
debugging in the browser so you know if
you have a
web application you've written some
webassembly you want to be able to debug
it you probably want to do that in the
browser
um how does that work uh you can do
printf debugging in the browser
sometimes called console.log
debugging but uh you know you also might
want to do something a little more
complicated as well
um and how does that work and then
finally like debugging outside of the
browser
you don't have any of the affordances
the browser has and like you don't
necessarily like know how to print stuff
to the screen because you know you would
need the format to like describe that
and so i think the the real key here is
that debugging means different things to
different people
and they do it in different environments
and so that's fundamentally what makes
this challenging is that like
you can't just say like okay this is how
we're going to debug the code
you need to be able to support people in
whatever way they want to do the
debugging and whatever environment they
want to do they're bugging in
so we talk about working on debugging
for webassembly that's going to be like
one of the largest challenges that
happens
there's also some other challenges too
beyond that part um
so we as we have mentioned earlier we
don't have the source code the wasm file
does not store the source code of our
program at all and we've sort of lost
that in translation
but when we do our debugging we don't
probably want to look at the actual
output we want to
look at the source code of the language
that we wrote it in so that's also like
a problem
and as i mentioned before we have
different environments browsers dev
don't have dev tools or like capital d
capital t dev tools right like i think
it only makes sense in the context of
the browser
um but uh when you think about these
problems like
another like sort of big issue here is
there's even different like
amounts of instructions so when i wrote
the rust i said x plus one
but if you look at the body of the the
webassembly text format
that x plus one is actually kind of like
two
or even three instructions depending on
how you think about it
there's the get the value of the local
variable which is the argument that's
passed in
then there's the like push one onto the
stack
with the second line there and then
there's add which pops those two numbers
off adds them and pushes the result back
on
so these kind of three steps in the
webassembly thing
correspond to one step in our source
code so like
if we wanted to step through the
webassembly instructions
do we like keep the source one at the
same line do we step through the source
code but we jump a number of webassembly
instructions like
this is also a kind of an interesting
challenge whenever you're translating
back and forth between formats
even in this kind of very small
webassembly file we run into this
problem
um so that's kind of like the problem
set here um
now we're going to talk about how people
are solving that currently so
um i'm going to explain the current
state but what i want to also impress on
you is that
this is a really active area of
development in a web assembly and so a
lot of stuff is in flux
this may not be the stuff i'm talking
about like may not be the final story
we're actually gonna talk about
one sort of like false start um and so
it looks like people are in a decent
place but we're not done yet and there's
some
some reasons why that's true and we're
gonna talk about it um and then finally
like there's a lot of work left to do
um all this is kind of like demo
quality i would say um people have not
really done a whole lot of this like in
production
and so uh you know that means that
things might change based on that sort
of feedback so um you know this is like
very very a cutting edge kind of area
that leads us to our third section elf
dwarf and source maps
um so uh as i've been talking about this
i've kind of been presenting this as
like a novel problem but you may be like
hey
we also compile our javascript not just
in like the sense that v8 has a jit and
does just in time compilation
but also like we transpile and minify
our javascript and so that's like a kind
of compilation on its own
and we don't have the original source
code whenever we send our compiled or
minified and transpiled javascript to
the browser
and people needed to debug those
applications and to do that they added
source maps
and so source maps kind of like it says
it maps the source code to
the like output it's javascript source
code and that's how your browser's dev
tools is able to kind of like
understand where in your original code
the new javascripts you know
what it respon corresponds to so the
um the initial thought behind how to
debug webassembly is like hey
we do this we have this problem in
javascript we solved it with source maps
so why not use source maps with wasm and
that seems totally fine
mozilla actually did this back in 2017
um this is a a tweet from flocky
uh who worked mozilla on uh and talking
about showing this like
uh person was presenting uh that in
firefox nightly
you could use source maps to show uh you
know webassembly
um being uh in the browser and so you
can see some rust code there in the
firefox dev tools um and so that like
totally worked
and people were excited about it there's
just one problem
uh it's actually not great um
and uh this is a quote from ingvar uh
sometimes known as reverser
on the internet uh we're gonna talk a
little more about where this quote comes
from in a second but basically
source maps were designed uh for
javascript
and so there's some things about them
i'm not going to get into what those
things are but just the point is when
you design something for javascript
but you need to use it for something
else it may not be as good at that
something else as it was for javascript
and that's tricky so basically
there's a bunch of problems with this
approach and so a lot of people said you
know what we don't actually really want
to use source maps to solve this problem
so what do you do well also during the
beginning of the presentation if you do
a lot of native tooling you may be like
hey
people have had to deal with these
problems for a long time like when you
compile your c code into a binary and
run it you don't have the c
source code anymore so like that's the
same problem we're talking about it's
not a novel problem it's existed for a
really long time
c has existed for a long time and other
languages that uh you know weren't c
also like anything that's compiled in a
binary directly has this problem
um and people have been debugging for a
very long time so
why don't we take the problem the stuff
that they use to solve their problems
and apply it to webassembly instead
so rather than copying javascript maybe
we should copy c
and other native languages
so this actually sort of is kind of true
with webassembly itself
this idea of like sections and a binary
i'm sure it comes from a lot of places
but there's this thing called elf which
is short for the executable and linkable
format
and this is the the way that programs
that run
on your linux system um or other similar
like unix systems
this is the format they follow so just
like webassembly binary as a structure
your programs like the binary files on
your hard drive also have a structure
and if there are linux programs they'll
follow this elf format
um and so web assemblies share some
similarities i think some of this is
just due to direct experience
some of this is also just because like
it's worked since the 70s so
our 80s i guess um and so like uh why
reinvent all the wheels and like these
time-tested solutions to problems
so there's differences obviously but
like a lot of there's a lot of
similarities especially if you squint
um and so uh like
that's how binaries are done there so
that's how binaries are done so what
does elf use for debugging
well because the people who made these
formats are giant nerds
uh elf has a debugging format called
dwarf because
that's a funny joke elves and dwarves uh
and so dwarf
uh you know does is this debugging
format that's used uh to
figure out debugging information from a
particular elf
uh program and so in the rust world we
kept
by using packages like christmas elf
which
uh is a library for dealing with elf
data in rust
and then gimli which is a library for
using dwarf
uh because ziemly's dwarf if you're a
tolkien fan
um and so uh so yeah so there's a rich
amount of puns in this area and that's
how you know something is good the more
jokes it has right
so anyway uh so wasm learned a lot from
elf like i said
and so why shouldn't debugging like
learn from dwarf um
it's a format it's been used for a long
time it's pretty good um
dwarf tends to be a very unix-centered
thing windows has its own thing called
pe
to deal with this um but like uh you
know
if it worked once why not do it again
and so this is kind of the direction
things are going it seems like people
think that using
instant uh using source maps and so
there's these attempts to move stuff
into uh that so like the brow like
dwarf there's like great tools for
debugging with dwarf uh
on the native platform but not a web
browser so we're kind of this funny kind
of opposite situation where
webassembly was originally made to be
great
we're kind of moving the tooling from
outside the browser into the browser and
some
web applications have only really dealt
with source maps before
so they don't like have native format
support for
dwarf like many other native tools do
but since they do similar things like we
can make it work
and so that's the approach that google
has been taking lately
by basically this is ingvar so the quote
from earlier was
from this blog post called improved web
assembly debugging chrome dev tools
but uh devtools and chrome have been
like basically adding support for dwarf
so you'd be able to load up those things
and so it kind of feels very similar in
many ways the same way where if you want
people to be able to debug in the
browser you ship source maps
this is like instead if you want to be
able to debug the browser you ship dwarf
and then the
you're able to do that um but it's not
totally done yet
while the basics work and you can check
it out there's some additional problems
that are being worked through
to make it more robust and also to
support some other things so for example
when i ran wasm pack
uh it not only generated the web
assembly but then optimized it by
shrinking stuff even further
and so the problem is the dwarf will get
generated on the first step but then we
transformed the binary more
and we didn't update the dwarf so it's
wrong so you would like end up with
weird results
and so there's work needed to be done in
all of these tools to kind of like plumb
everything through the stack in the
right way to make sure that things are
like working out
and that's true also of chrome's
implementation itself it's not complete
and not done
and uh you know putting it in other
browsers and things as well so this is
very much an active area of development
and that's kind of the intention is that
hopefully you just ship these debugging
files along with your web application
and you'll be able to use all of your
native um debugging tools in the browser
to be able to debug webassembly in the
browser
and then you can use gdb or lldb or any
of your other native debuggers
with that dwarf as well to debug things
that are outside of the browser and
we've kind of like
unified the universe everything works
and is happy um
but i think one thing that's interesting
about this and uh basically this is i'm
done here but i wanted to mention like
yeah this is all a work in progress
there's tons of room to like improve
these tools and
we'll see maybe there'll be a bigger
problem with dwarf and people decide to
invent a new format instead
um google seems to be really pursuing
this
um approach and doing a lot of work on
it um
and then but there's also like web
assembly outside of the browser um
there's lots of buzz mozilla seems to be
more focused these days on outside of
the browser than in the browser
this is kind of like me looking from the
outside like i don't know what these
organizations are doing but it seems to
me like google's really working on
browser wasm and brazil is working on
like
wazzy stuff and that's really cool
because it's great to use webassembly
everywhere
but it's also interesting because the
the tools are a little bit better
in native than not um and so i think
there's more interest in working on wazi
itself natively rather than worrying
about dwarf right now
so it's like kind of unclear how much
this is going to get sorted out on what
time frame but there are people working
on
all sorts of aspects of this problem and
so i think that we're going to see a
very healthy ecosystem for wasm both
inside and outside of the browser
and we'll need to deal with the
debugging problems in both ways and so
it's great that
all these different companies are
working on this stuff and all the
different people who work at those
companies they're working on this stuff
so with that that is the end of my talk
uh thanks so much for listening